started to rain again in Minsk so I'm
gonna go down under the city and check
out this metro got a glimpse of it
yesterday and saw some spectacular
sights for sure these soviet metros boys
have something interesting going on
usually some soviet realism some art
there's a bird
it's rustic
roughly was that 30 cents so super cheap
to get around definitely the cheapest
way to get around the city
[Music]
the station has a
starry sky theme going on
quite cool never seen this in a metro
just pop it out for a bit it's cleared
out and few observations few interesting
observations firstly it's super safe
here in the metro I'm sure there are
some pickpocketers but there are a ton
of cameras and there's I didn't feel any
edge in there and so that's that's an
interesting thing about this part of the
world is I think it's because of all the
Hollywood movies the Slovak guy is
always the bad guy
the the villain and then there's not
that it's not that smiling culture
obviously some people look hard but it's
not an agressive culture it's really not
super chill and just because they look
pissed off doesn't mean they are so the
smiles are very authentic and real but
nobody just smiles just a smile like
it's not a thing that happens in this
country so yeah nice Metro super clean
safe interesting some cool fonts
different styles
[Music]
[Applause]
the Minsk Metro has 29 stations roughly
900,000 people travel every day on the
system and check this out here this is
the nuclear winter door so you'll see
these doors and everyone
every one of the soviet metros and
supposedly they have secret passageways
with enough food and water and rations
down here in case
anything did happen this one has two
doors most of them just have one this
one has two is that a third now you can
see it because the tracks the tracks
come apart here
on the bottom
[Music]
and not many people hear about two stops
from the center
check this out we have
the most interesting metro station and
right in front of me that's a little
taster teaser
and then down here
we have Lennon station obviously this
may get closer to the center
you can see something quite interesting
and it feels quite surreal to be honest
quite powerful definitely different
as you can see this
the station is very clean everything is
very clean even in the tracks normally
that's where a lot of junk collects on
Minsk
very efficient too
so these trains come on a regular basis
meaning like every two two-and-a-half
minutes
there's a new trend all this one's
taking a little longer but it's cool
they have a timer clock that you can see
when they're actually coming okay I Spit
off on this one three and a half minutes
not too bad
[Music]
that's my tour of the Minsk Metro and
for locals I'm sure there's somebody
saying what the hell is so interesting
about that and I'll tell you what's
interesting our metro suck for the most
part in the US I'm gonna compare New
York or San Francisco I don't know them
all
this is different this is interesting
there's art in the air there's all this
crazy all these features like nuclear
doors the hammer and sickle Lenin that's
an outsider I think it's much more of a
novelty obviously I get a lot out of
this I find these places super
interesting because a lot of money was
put into these metros like the style or
not they have something to them
now we're downtown Minsk and out clear
it up quite a bit
it was raining all day it's really a
beautiful city so check out my other
video I got a video I actually did on
Minsk and well anymore
about other countries in the world ok
peace